all right picture this you're shroud and you
load into an apex legend server you make it
to the final three and you are cruising to an
easy dub but then out of nowhere this happens
oh well hot dab okay your first reaction
would have to be that this kid's a cheater
right he's got 12 frags oh he's cheating
unless he's just really good wait is he insane
but as shroud quickly learned the tempest
he found himself in was all too real
i'm the best player get out of my lobby on
that day shroud stepped into the cross harris
of monsoon an up-and-coming apex legends player
these days the 21 year old is one of the biggest
names in apex but to get there he didn't just
have to battle his way through online arenas
and aim trainers he had to fight homelessness
throughout all the homelessness the one thing
that i did keep was my computer
competing in overwatch realm real
so many different games trying to make anything
work from working in a kitchen for 60 hours a
week to setting up his pc in a taco bell monsoon
did whatever it took to be a pro gamer and since
then he's taken competitive apex by storm and
gentrifying he's the last remaining player
in complexity they have it within their grasp
they push in it's gonna be the moment for them
complexity get the story
they so desperately wanted
all right folks before we get into monsoon's
incredible story i want to make sure that you
are all sub to the channel so please hit the
sub button hit that notification bell and help
us get to 2 million subs alright back to monsoon
now before he was complexity's star apex fragger
monsoon and his family had a lot of financial
difficulties when he was growing up he spent
most of his childhood sleeping in cars tents and
hotel rooms and he was homeless as a teenager
i grew up in the bay area of california during
my prime years of high school and middle school
and spent on and off about two years homeless
not only did monsoon's living situation prevent
him from finishing high school but he and his wife
had to hop from state to state just to make ends
meet at one point they were sleeping on a table
in a trailer that was home to five people and
three dogs in fact the only way that monsoon
was able to stay afloat was his other passion
cooking he grinded at a 60 hour a week
kitchen job that paid him 14 dollars an hour
still monsoon's real goal was
to become a professional gamer
one more stop frozen friends he stopped
pushing stop brandon selfridge stop
friends he tried everything from cs go to
realm royale and was determined to bring
his talents to some game's world stage i'm not
an engagement right now so i can take that uh
oh [ __ ] but since he didn't have a stable
place to live monsoon had to set up his pc
anywhere he could taking any and every
opportunity to grind he even played in a
taco bell buying baja blast every hour to stay
on the wi-fi while he was trying to qualify for
an overwatch team a lot of times i've set
up my pc in friends houses or pc cafes or
hotels or anywhere that i really
could to kind of get on practice
but then at the start of 2019 a new shooter
emerged apex legends this is my favorite part
exciting part hero shooter part battle royale
apex was a dream come true for monsoon within
no time he was fragging out on twitch determined
to make himself one of the game's first stars
eventually monsoon quit his restaurant
job to commit to apex full time
he moved to las vegas and cut his teeth
on weeklies for the better part of a year
before getting signed by flyquest what's going
on everybody flyquest apex family my name is
monsoon i'm one of the three players for apex
legends uh flyquest's roster and then in august
2019 playing a random match under flyquest banner
monsoon hit the flick that would change his life
after popping off on shroud in front of the entire
world monsoon became an overnight sensation yeah
that's the best player at apex legends
seven thousand viewers holy fudge
dude shroud thank you so much for shouting out me
sent by i appreciate you so much homie in addition
to being absolutely cracked monsoon was also super
charismatic and injected tons of personality into
his gameplay no grave can hold my body down in
the fall he flew to poland to compete in the
apex legends pre-season invitational and then
the reason why i want to start with flyquest is
because monsoon has recently joined them he was a
substitute for tempo storm uh way back at x games
and he is one of the most individually skilled
players that we have at this tournament especially
when it comes to sniping and using the longbow
etc or the craiber look at flyquest now it's a
one it's right now mvp versus flyquest this is not
a match point game but one of these teams will win
it's gonna be one knock here for mvp two knocks
yes indeed mvp closes it out and we have more
apex legends still to come tonight unfortunately
flyquest hadn't quite worked out their kinks
and despite making it to the tournament's final
day they finished in a disappointing 17th place
it took us good seven games to get
rolling unfortunately that's not
anything that we enjoy doing and our
moral morale was was pretty pretty low man
within three months of joining flyquest monsoon
was picked up by complexity where he'd be able
to practice at a state-of-the-art training
facility in texas signing to complexity is the
best thing that's ever happened in my life this
organization is the best org in the entire world
over the course of the next year monsoon worked
tirelessly to break into the top tier of na apex
unfortunately complexity consistently struggled
to make it past top four despite monsoon's
incredible individual achievements and then
through the barrel monsoon's gonna connect for
another one squad left complexity is hunting
they smell blood they're gonna find it and
that's gonna be a victory coming through for
complexity what a performance from this squad
the situation only got worse as complexity came
out of the second summer circuit in an unthinkable
12th place something had to change and complexity
made a roster move trying to turn things around
now shawnee's got to finish off this job in a big
massive shot make that two and he's doing all of
the work here for complexity even though monsoon
went down the damage that he'd done once again
let's take a look at what they see on the board
everybody collective side complexity breaking it
out on top with 68 points sadly come playoffs
complexity's old habits caught up with them
despite coming into the tournament as a juggernaut
they couldn't quite secure that top spot
complexity the only one on the
ground currently in zone with tlg
able to find something complexity
looks like they're the ones going
down it's complexity down but clg is still
alive the shotgun battle is here it's two
they are your champions of the americas in summer
after finishing first second and third in each of
the respective autumn circuits complexity went
into the year's final playoff spout as a bit of
a question mark but when the chips were down and
monsoon had a chance to come up huge for his team
he did the impossible complexity does have
the player advantage here monsoon going in
trying to take down the last player
which is eures he actually does it
and gentrifying he's the last remaining player
in complexity they have it within their grasp
they push in it's gonna be the moment for them
complexity get the story they so desperately
wanted since discovering apex back in 2019 monsoon
has gone from a nomad to a world-class competitor
he's beaten nearly insurmountable odds to
become not only one of his region's finest
fraggers but also it's most inspiring he's run
his race achieved his dream and shown time and
time again that for a lot of people esports isn't
just entertainment it's a way for literally anyone
to pull themselves up by their bootstraps and
turn their passion into success and stability
because against every odd that's exactly
what monsoon did thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and facebook pages